huge number of sexual assault and
harassment survivors are sharing their
stories online it happened to me too me
too
it happened to me too and it happened to
me too this is my story an untold number
of women posted me to and revealed their
deeply intimate experiences of abuse
their stories flooded social media and
painted a picture of just how many
people endure sexual abuse and
harassment every day Jericka Duncan is
here with why these women are coming
forward now Jericka good morning good
morning you know these survivors are
sharing their personal stories of
harassment and assault online many of
the women spoke to we say they are
reliving painful personal traumas while
hoping to break the cycle I decided to
call it rape because I was blacked out
drunk and I was taken advantage of I
don't remember what happened
sharing her experience as a rape
survivor has been empowering for Haley
Jacobsen it's my truth and no one can
take that away from me it's my story
Jacobsen wrote on Facebook Monday I woke
up today knowing it was time I published
this because I would do anything to have
had these words at 16 me too and I was
blamed for it I was told not to talk
about it I was 9 years old when the
child sexual abuse started the massive
response to hashtag me to demonstrated
what many women already know Americans
are sexually assaulted every 98 seconds
and one in six women have faced rape it
took me years to label what happened to
me as sexual assault Pittsburgh City
Councilwoman Natalia Rudy AK wrote in a
Facebook post Monday no one would even
dare suspect I've been raped but I have
it happened to me she continued I'd been
touched inappropriately by donors and
come on to by so-called political allies
and physically intimidated by men and
politics I never won in my political
adversaries to see this as a
vulnerability to exploit I never wanted
to be seen as weak there's no more room
for judgement there's no more room for
shaming
Witney wolf herd is the founder and CEO
of the social platform bumble she says
the digital harassment she experienced
ultimately influenced her business model
I was being harassed daily we really
have a zero-tolerance policy for
harassment in our platform or at our
office it's incredibly important that we
all in our own respective fields and
industries look in the mirror and say
what are we doing to be a part of the
solution not a part of the problem these
personal stories are just the tip of the
iceberg many of the women that we spoke
to said that they've trying to spread a
greater understanding of how often
harassment and assault happens in our
society some women online are calling
for men now to admit when they have
harassed or assaulted someone as a
result the hashtag I have is appearing
on social media using the digital event
there's everything see Alyssa Milano
started this right correct and it's
interesting to see she said you know
it's darkest this is the light of this
is that so many people have the
opportunity now to share what they've
been holding inside yeah amazing how
many women we spoke to on the phone
through Twitter who shared their story
for the first time and said they felt so
empowered by being able to say me too
but it's it's a sad story to tell that
there are so many people that have that
imagine holding it in and then realizing
listen I'm not alone we know that and
that other people are supporting you and
actually cheering you on to speak up but
what I think is important too is for the
men to speak up and say this is not okay
absolutely not okay they need to be a
big part of this conversation
well said Eureka thank you very much